mon score au premier tour n'a évidemment
pas été à la hauteur de mes espérances
et je le disais hier soir constitue
évidemment une très grande déception
pour moi la politique est parfois cruel
pour autant je sais que ces deux idées
celle des ordonnances et du réarmement
de la france ont recueilli un fort
ressentiment populaire
je continuerai à les défendre sans
relâche auprès des françaises et des
français
dans l'esprit de cette droite
décomplexée que j'appelle de mes voeux
c'est la défense de ses idées qui me
conduise à apporter mon soutien pour le
deuxième tour alain juppé tout en
laissant à mes amis une totale liberté
de choix